j'accueille muriel robin
bonsoir muriel ressentir et ce vin est
ce que tu as fait quoi ce truc se
brasser c'est samuel benchetrit qui me
l'a offert pourquoi ça veut dire quoi
qu'avec à être là j'ai vu un peu en
jambes a bien non et qu'en pense jean
yanne c'est bien mais ça casse un peu le
look at me coupe les cheveux avoir
pendant la grossesse
samuel guy contre ça fait rebelles
bonsoir et bk alors s'il est ton
actualité et rebecca ces familles un
trône ont cette option de mamie alors
muriel robin vous avez déclaré au
quotidien belge la dernière heure le 7
décembre 2005 la télévision je déteste
la preuve j'en ai même pas chez moi
les plateaux je me rends uniquement
parce qu'il le faut pour la promotion à
la télé faut faire rire immédiatement en
se mettant au service des animateurs pas
nécessairement drôles ou talentueux
conclusion je n'aime pas ce que je
souhaitais vous qu'est ce que tu sais
moi le tourner ce que c'est beaucoup
c'est bon c'est plus doux que ça je vous
aviez dit et plus doux que ça c'est pas
pour vous avez raison fissures non je
n'aime pas la télé je crois que c'est
parce que j'ai pas ce qu'on peut pas
avoir du talent partout il faut en avoir
là aussi pour le texte n'est pas préparé
et que voilà il faudra du talent aussi
parce que quand vous passez beaucoup de
gens que vous regarde et que voilà et à
la sortie on peut vous dire que je
trouvais bien ou pas bien tu as dis ça
donc on est encore au front et c'est
moins facile je veux dire merial
on donne et je vais déclarer noyade en
avoir fini avec le one woman show avec
les sketches pour vous consacrer au
théâtre et au cinéma
vous avez changé la vie vous êtes revenu
avec un spectacle sans sketch c'est
peut-être le cinéma qu'à changer de vie
un spectacle en skate et les sketchs
jeudi je fais je ne savais pas si
j'arrêtais les sketchs voilà votre
spectacle au secours coécrit avec pierre
palmade
ce n'est pas une succession de sketches
ces deux heures dans la vie d'une femme
qui a eu l'idée de monter blanche neige
et les sept nains en comédie musicale
on est à 15 jours de la première autour
d'elle tout s'agite et on suit ce
personnage comme ça lise là qui parle à
19 personnes qui sont pas là qui est
assez pratique parce que vous avez une
fois le dit je me cogne pas une
comédienne qui jouerait estelle et qui
mettrait six secondes à sortir oui c'est
formidable ça a très vite la personne
est là et en seconde elle est sortie
pour le rythme parce que c'est très
important ça compte beaucoup pour moi
c'est un rythme
il ya du bon dans le fait d'être
saperait les personnages et tu attendais
les répliques avec guy bedos attendait
tant des communes suivantes il revenait
à 1219 s'ils étaient tous là
400 m haies gens soient leurs croyances
en a pas une seconde alors vous jouez
vous chantez vous dansez vous avez si
boys autour de vous et c'est trés
procédure à faire ce que vous faites là
ce qui est dur c'est de rester 1h50 avec
eu des mots avec 4000 personnes faire
que le temps s'arrête
être drôle avec des choses qui ne le
sont pas et être son propre héros aixois
en tordant une barre à chaque fois se
disant ex à l'air d'être facile c'est
cette difficulté qui ne voit qu on ne
voit pas qui rend cette de ce maître
c'est beau mais qui fait que c'est que
cette affaire tous les soirs et c'est
aussi difficile tous les soirs c'est
difficile à chaque fois neuf oui de
faire partout tout le temps là on a
voulu de de les tenir de ne pas les
perdre d'être voilà au millimètre cet
édifice où il aurait accès difficile
mais parce que j'ai choisi que ce soit
les fissures et ce que sinon je
m'ennuierais vous avez quatre cinq mille
personnes tous les soirs au total 300
mille spectateurs
c'était fin journée à 424 formule
km qu'elle sent même pour tous combien
de personnes par kilomètre et alors le
dvd lui il est pré vendu à 300 mille
exemplaires ce qui gère tous les
fermions de 1 million de dvd quoi je
sais pas si ça existe à la cigale et
jamel il faut un million c'est pas un
million dvd à 20 euros le dvd muriel
jacques leconte et redonne à l'afrique
aussi moba normal ou à l'asie d'asie
c'est énorme alors on va regarder à quoi
ça ressemble il a regardé votre caméra
quand c'est le cas le rouge
oui et vous allez dire magnéto serge
magnéto serge bien